good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy
Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday everybody's
looking forward to the week and we and
Friday Friday get down Friday hey Jax
how you doing
not well [__] me neither I pulled my
neck
and I can't move like I'm in pain and
I'm like I I really can't I'm Zoolander
I can't turn it's real it's not only
like inconvenient but it's extremely
painful so my dance moves for the Friday
jingle were not giving
they're a little stiff for sure at least
though thankfully I was able to give my
all to the 1000 dance okay I thought you
were gonna say you're not well and then
I was like me neither because we're not
together
oh yeah just to add misery on top of
misery to add insult to injury it's
literally so true because if we were
together like yeah my neck would hurt
and we would talk about it but it'd be
okay because we're together but like I
had to I had to put my studio back
together with a creaked out neck and I'm
just literally not okay if we were
together I definitely would massage you
and we would be so happy together we
would even though massage like doesn't
help for a pulled neck no there are a
few things in life that are truly worse
than having like a thrown out back or a
strained neck because you don't even
realize it your back is something you
take for granted like it just works you
know knock wood thank God Hashem every
day and it isn't until you're like
inconvenienced in the most minor way
when it comes to your back your neck
that you realize how your whole body
relies on your back and your neck and
it's like the place where it's pulled is
kind of in between my neck and my back
so it's kind of both areas are impacted
by this injury I'm I'm beside myself I'm
so sorry
excuse me I sneezed on it it's true it's
true that you're sorry I and I really am
I have a lot of sympathy I've thrown out
my back it's it's debilitating and I
don't even have any children like you
still gotta you know your mom I know it
was really hard this morning but it
happened in the middle of the morning
like I swear I sneezed and I was like
that didn't feel right somebody's knees
can kill you usually I wake up with it
because I like kind of sleep weird with
all my pillows like I'm doing it to
myself but it was the sneeze I the
sneeze through my neck that's the thing
people always ask like when you throw
out your back what happened you know
were you you know using a forklift like
no when I threw my back out the first
time I literally bent down to plug in my
phone charger it's like it's always the
most like innocuous regular daily life
thing such as [__] throw out your
back it's never anything even like
overtly physical it was a sneeze you
guys you guys got to watch out for the
sneeze you better you better watch out
for them sneezes because they tell you
like be you know wash your hands you
don't want to get a cold
but you don't want to throw your back
out either right and maybe I bent over
the sink a little weird while washing my
hands and now I have it thrown out back
but I have clean hands if I wash my
hands I wouldn't have a cold and then I
wouldn't have sneezed and thrown my back
it all comes back to like proper hygiene
doesn't everything
well today's episode is really special
because you know we're not together and
it's fine it's fine but it is our last
show before the Super Bowl and I think
we got to make some predictions you know
people kind of have come to rely on us I
was in the middle of ordering my Super
Bowl groceries and I forgot to hit order
oh well I got I had to stock up on just
the Necessities in the house milk yeah
Harry drinks milk now oh yeah grown ass
man [__]
I like how you got your license and you
have a car and you still order your
groceries online now it's about finding
the time to go right like I I really
intended for this to be like an
in-person Excursion but
um we don't have the time plus now with
the neck it's just not gonna happen
um I had to get like some cleaning
supplies for the house and then I'm
making nachos like I told you so I
ordered all the ingredients got some
more tater tots yogurt fruits butter you
know just a restock just the regular
everyday household items because I'm a
regular everyday householder Frau you
really are a regular everyday household
for out
um I still have no plans for the Super
Bowl but like I can't really think about
the Super Bowl I haven't even really
like started to tell everyone about how
like I'm kind of like so busy next week
um like I don't wanna you know I thought
there was just like the one thing yeah
but it's like a really big thing
about it so the rest of your week is
kind of like wide open no I'm like gonna
be thinking about it for the rest of the
week probably like you know lamenting on
what I did wrong or what I could have
done better but so on Monday Not only
was I invited to Cynthia Rally's fashion
show but it's kind of like a celebration
of women in comedy so there's like you
know five or six really premium female
Comics not only walking in the show but
I think we're also do doing like a
little set
um and I'm one of them and it's not like
it's a big deal like Nikki Glazer's
there too she's like a real comedian you
know Eggo notum from SNL and your girl
is tapped and I'm so honored and I'd
like to thank you know Keenan I'd like
to thank Keenan's Mom I'd like to thank
everyone who made this possible I'm very
excited you know because I'm like a
fashion girly I'm like a comedy girly so
I'm like it's really like a blend of
your two passions fashion you know art
and comedy yeah well I have some a joke
if you want to include it oh hit me up
hit me up okay because it's a Cynthia
rally fashion show so we say hey
everyone
welcome to Cynthia rally
Jesus excuse me excuse me I I thought of
it last night and then you'll say hmm
Cynthia
Jesus Cynthia
Jesus died for our
cynthias okay I thought of it last night
and if people don't laugh you need to
leave because that's not your kind of
crowd so okay once I say it and they
don't laugh I'm gonna say well my sister
said if you guys don't laugh I have to
leave so thanks so much for having me
have a great night everyone like
uncultured swine but wait you want to
hear something even crazier I've never
seen that movie so you and Margo are
always doing that slime poetry thing
Cynthia Jesus died for our Cynthia and I
like know it because of you guys but I
literally don't even know like I know
it's 22 Jump Street but like I don't
know the reference like I don't know
anything so there's a murder on campus a
death I'm sorry it's a death
um of a girl named Cynthia and they have
like a slam poetry evening like dedic no
they just have selling poetry and she
like Jonah Hill is like trying to
impress a girl and slam poetry so he
said he wrote A Sign poetry about
Cynthia the girl who passed the deceased
and he got up there and he said Cynthia
Jesus died for our cynthias it's kind of
good yeah there was more too it was
really beautiful yeah I gotta write some
jokes I'm still you know I'm still
waiting to be told like what exactly I'm
doing so then I can you know
write some material but I think I'm also
walking in the show and that I'm like
extremely ill prepared for I can barely
walk down the street without like
picking my wedgie I literally picked my
wedgie
on my way to work today and I was
thinking my underwear was like so far
out my vagina and I was like I never see
other people picking their wedgies yet
here I am constantly like
wedgie picking
well maybe it's just one of those
situations where it's like you don't
notice things about like uh people don't
notice things about other people they
just notice it about themselves like I
just feel like wedgie picking is like
noticeable yeah I would just pretend
like I didn't see it I was just like no
I would forget about it I would not
pretend I didn't see it I would feel it
would like immediately bring me like
peace I'm like oh my God another
gorgeous girl no no because when you
pick a wedgie like it's not gross but
when someone else does like you're
literally seeing their fingers go into
their butt it's
okay not in their butt it's like around
their cheek but like but like
it has butt stuff yeah no totally like
then you're like spreading fecal matter
onto your hands and onto the subway and
onto the doorknobs yeah like it's not uh
it's like a there's a lot of relief when
you pick your own wedgie but to see
someone else do it is all gross
so true
um so that's what I've like kind of
preoccupied like I know it's a Super
Bowl this weekend but like I'm focused
on my big performance on Monday I got my
fitting later today so I'm just like I'm
nervous to be real like I'm nervous
you're gonna be amazing thank you it's
all your passions all you have to do is
just be yourself
they're gonna love you turdy and if they
don't you know fashion shows are really
quick like so true it'll be over in a
Flash and they'll be running to the next
one
so true and then you could place a bit
you know I'm not first I'm not last I'm
third which is like a really good number
if you're not first you're last
no I disagree
I disagree
uh yes
middle of the pack you are right so if I
stink like they'll just so they won't
even remember yeah but if you're amazing
they'll be like where's that middle girl
yeah no and that's fine by me yeah
um so let's go over some of our Super
Bowl prediciones okay
um do we have any stories about the
Super Bowl should we save that Brianna
okay okay so I won't talk about Rihanna
but we can talk about the actual game
which is what we're obsessed with anyway
oh so true uh Chiefs versus Eagles who
you got Jax
I'm torn because I would like I would
prefer for the Chiefs to win by a slight
margin like I'm not
Jason Kelsey's really closing the gap on
that yeah but I think the Eagles are
going to win I think it's the Eagles
time
yeah I I kind of support everything you
just said you know as a New York fan
like you really can't root not New York
fan like New Yorker it's a kind of
illegal to root for the Eagles
especially you know on top of that given
the fact that the reason the 49ers
aren't in the Super Bowl is because of
the Eagles so I really I can't [__] with
the Eagles especially like I have a
toxic relationship with Philly like I
it's gonna be a note for me even though
like not even that jazzed about the
chiefs no I'm not even like that too
either
agreed it feels like everyone in the
country who's not doesn't have Philly
ties like will not root for Philly do
you know what I mean they don't make it
easy no it's like Zach he's from Dallas
he's like well I can't root for the
Eagles oh really what's your beef what
is his beef I don't like the I guess the
Cowboys hate like everybody hates them
everyone hates them except for them it's
so true I kind of love that for them
though no it's giving villain energy
it's giving toast yes you either love
them or you hate them there it's giving
Danielle Stout there is no in between
with them no so I kind of like now
respect it that way I relate I respect
it you know I feel like if the Eagles
were a team they would have done 1000
episodes
they have history is what you're saying
you and me got a whole lot of history oh
no that's such a good song and it's so
true because we do have a lot of history
I would say 1 000 episodes of History
yeah so this is one thousand and one
um we came back you guys you thought
maybe we'd retire after a thousand maybe
we'd like take a hint it's too many
episodes but no no by the way our
episode like over performed yesterday
like our numbers were through the roof
because everybody was tuning in to see
that turnt performance of ours so if
anything has been reinvigorated for
another thousand another thousand and
we're almost at our five year
anniversary which means it was just
under five years that it took us I was
saying it was five inches yes it's four
and three quarters so we'll see in
another four and three quarters Hashem
God willing we'll see you in another
four and three quarters I feel like
people who love this show like live in
fear that it's gonna end and no matter
how many times we tell them like girlies
even if we were offered let's say the
dead ass one of us or both of us like we
were offered a job on like the talk or
one of those like daytime daily shows
like I would still do this like I don't
think I would even want that no I feel
like you would want that as as long as
you could still do this but you would
never choose like a seat on a rotating
cast of clowns yeah where you could lose
your seat at any time and the show could
go under when like we've got a good
thing going I always say it's like you
know people will be like Jax Jax do you
think you've outgrown the toast it's
like can Queen Elizabeth outgrow the
throne no this is a job for Life
literally it's really like being a
Supreme Court Justice it's a lifelong
job
literally the show like will not end so
I just need everyone to like relax 30.
this is a show that never ends it must
go on and on my friends some people
started listening not knowing what it
was and they'll just keep on listening
because this is just because this is a
show that never ends
my life is broken friends
um gorgeous rendition absolutely you
know I love that song and I know you
hate that song so I like it when there's
a remix that's applicable to my
situation remix
um so thanks to everyone for the kind
words yesterday we got a lot of feedback
people were kind of guffawed that we
thought that there was you know not a
single person out there who's listened
to every single episode we were flooded
with comments about people flooded I
have no doubt listened to every episode
that includes patreon includes guests so
I'm feeling I'm actually feeling
reinvigorated and I think a lot of the
times we say this all the time when you
do the same thing every day you know
sometimes it starts to feel like you
know you're shouting into the void or
just like speaking into an echo chamber
and like you're like is anyone even
listening like you see the numbers but
it doesn't feel like real people and I
think yesterday you know a lot of people
who are mostly silent listeners the show
is just a part of their daily routine
they don't need you know to send
messages or leave comments they just
love the show for what it is so many of
the silent listeners came out just like
dropped a comment be like hey look I
never comment just love the show
congrats on DMS and I have like a new
reinvigorated sense of self yeah and
there were so many people I thought
there would maybe be like one or two
who've listened to every thousand but
people were like no I've been listening
since the beginning and even when I miss
an episode I will not listen to the next
one until I've caught up on the other
one so no and there were people who were
like I started listening two years ago
and I went back to the beginning and
started from scratch yeah they'll be
like if you check my podcast app there
is nothing that's like yeah
so I'd love that it's a great way to
start the weekend with gratitude in our
hearts gratitude with a reinvigorated
spirit
and I think that's all you could really
ask for a Friday show honestly honestly
and a lot of musical stylings which
you're getting which you're getting
so without further Ado here are the fast
five stories that you need to know
before a Super Bowl weekend because the
next time that we see you we will know
who won the Super Bowl and we will see
Rihanna have performed for the first
time in many years it's true and what
Jackie just said is brought to you by
European Wax Center break away from the
winter Blues with a wax from the experts
book a service today at European Wax
Center
so European Wax Center's exclusive
Violet Comfort wax is formulated with
skin smoothing ingredients that provide
you with your best smooth all it takes
is 15 minutes whether you're jet setting
or just staying at home get the quick
refresh that you deserve in 15 minutes
or less you can extend your smooth at
home with our post-wax faves so each one
is designed to complement your wax and
maintain silky smooth skin all winter
long and if you're ready for a refresh
the first one is on them get your first
wax free at European Wax Center so I
feel like this is a great reminder like
just because it's the cold season like
don't stop your self-care because I
think I went through this recently where
like I just totally like stopped hair
removal for like a few weeks just
because I'm like it's winter who cares
and it kind of like makes you feel
like not gross but it's like you're not
upkeeping with your daily Beauty Tings
and making that reservation at European
Wax Center is just kind of going to
catapult you and like into a great
self-love era you know it's important to
take care of yourself just because it's
cool doesn't make me stop our routine
um European Wax centers are the experts
in waxing for everyone when you visit
you get the best of the best their
certified wax Specialists are expertly
trained in prepping protecting and
pampering your skin beat the winter
Blues with a wax from the experts keep
you silky smooth all season long with
15-minute appointments exclusive Comfort
wax and an array of post-wax products
beating the winter Blues is smoother
than ever before if you want to give it
a try your first wax is on the house get
your first wax free experience a new
state of smooth at European Wax Center
make a reservation today where your
first wax is free today's episode is
also brought to you by seed
so it's that time you guys
if you're into like habit stacking or um
just kind of getting your routine in a
good place seed is a really great place
to start they're ds01 daily symbiotic is
a plant-based Prebiotic and probiotic
with 24 strain that has been clinically
and scientifically studied for its
benefits so it's free from 14 classes of
allergens that are defined by the efsa
and that includes sugar-free vegan free
vegan soy free Sesame free gluten-free
peanut free
glyphosate ampa free dairy free
shellfish free corn free you take two
capsules once a day on the empty stomach
so it could be the first thing in the
morning basically 30 minutes before your
first meal or two hours after your last
meal and it's engineered to survive your
external and internal environments so
their capsule and capsule via cap
safeguards via viably get that capsule
through digestion for delivery of an
average of 100 of your probiotic
starting dose into your colon the outer
capsule also serves as an elegant
barrier for oxygen moisture and heat so
there's no Refrigeration necessary
um so it's just good for your digestive
health if you've been having trouble
with like bloating or just you know
making bsds big soft duties as we like
to call them
um take control of your tummy your
digestion your gut start taking the seed
pre and probiotic it makes an enormous
difference and it's just something that
you don't to worry about anymore just
like you know you'll be taking it every
day you'll be regular and you'll start
feeling good you won't feel like that
brick in your stomach that's the worst
feeling
um
it's just good for your gut barrier
Integrity gut immune function
micronutrient synthesis so avoid gut
Mania and head to the trusted source for
symbiotics start a new healthy habit
today visit seed.com toast and use code
toast to redeem 20 off your first month
of seeds ds01 daily symbiotic that's
seedseed.com toast and use code toast
today check it out it's the seeds ds01
daily symbiotic
thank you mclartia you're welcome
our first story Rihanna gave a great
interview saying she's pinching herself
over the combination of motherhood
Oscars and the Super Bowl so she told
Entertainment Tonight motherhood Oscars
Super Bowl I'm still pinching myself
really I'm grateful I'm grateful so not
only is Rihanna up for Grammy she just
had a baby and her first life Oscar
yeah that's that's what I meant sorry
blame the neck but I'm not gonna
challenge you I did say grammy yeah um
an Oscar
she's had a baby and she's performing in
the Super Bowl her first live
performance since 2017 she told the
outlet it really feels Like A lot's
happening at Once In the words of Luke
Combs when it rains it pours she also
held a press conference on Thursday by
Apple music the official sponsor of the
halftime show and she's so crazy it's
the first non-pepsi one she opened up
about preparing for this weekend's
career defining performance she said
Sunday now that's the one I've been so
focused on the Super Bowl I totally
forgot that my birthday's coming up I
totally forgot about Valentine's Day she
said among the biggest challenges for
her performance was choosing which songs
to choose she said quote that was the
hardest hardest part to starting her
deciding how to maximize 13 minutes but
also celebrate that's what this show is
going to be it's going to be a
celebration of my catalog and the best
way that we could have put it together
you're trying to cram 17 years of work
into 13 minutes so it's different
difficult yeah some songs we have to
lose because of that and that's going to
be okay but I think we did a pretty good
job of narrowing it down I also am so
curious about
um
if she's going to bring any guests
because so many of like her iconic songs
have features I mean I would just plot
if she's saying four or five seconds I
feel like she won't she won't um I know
but like maybe she could have brought
out Paul McCartney yeah but that like
when you think about her songs and her
big ones like they're so huge yeah like
they're Global four or five seconds
actually that's kind of register no but
also
umbrella diamonds
We Found Love in a hopeless place Don't
Stop the Music wait throw back Pon de
Replay I think she'll do Ponder replay
just because it was like her first kiss
I know I don't and I think it'll
probably be like a journey through her
music I love that if they go
chronologically I would really enjoy
that maybe not the whole time but like I
feel like the first song will be the
earliest and the last song will actually
maybe not because it's like about like
you know sometimes they start off slow
and it's like the best you better have
my money and then we're cranking it up
yeah so I actually I don't know if
she'll be chronological
I wonder what she'll choose from the
anti-era that was like one of her most
iconic eras Like Love on the brain I
know I work it's exciting work
if you should bring out DJ Khaled I like
hope like I like when they bring out
people but like honestly for Rihanna
this is such a moment people have been
waiting for something like this from
Rihanna for so long I wouldn't be mad if
she brought nobody out I feel like they
almost forced people to bring people out
like to make it more of a spectacle but
like Gloria had to do her thing I would
kind of prefer if she brought nobody out
Katy Perry brought people out Lady Gaga
brought nobody out nobody Lady Gaga's is
one of the best so and you know what
else I was thinking I mean I can't talk
about the Super Bowl halftime show
without talking about one of my favorite
stories Lady Gaga's five foot two the
documentary she made while getting ready
for the Super Bowl it was so interesting
and you know Rihanna has that big
streaming deal with Amazon Prime because
they do the Savage stuff I would love
love a documentary about getting ready
for this I feel like it's really
possible she also talks about getting
ready for it how this week's rehearsals
are just like make or break how it's the
biggest like craziest Endeavor
practically impossible what she's trying
to do the stage the dancers the breaking
it down of the stage also they they
shall be breaking it down I assume but
she didn't say that oh you mean like
physically breaking down the stage like
to get in and out in 15 minutes yes
eight minutes no she said it's 13
minutes no but the breaking it down uh
before putting it up and breaking it
down on the field yeah that's what I was
talking about too yeah yeah
um wait I think we're all talking about
that wait I had one more thing to say
but I'm oh seriously not okay I could
tell can you tell like I mean you sound
sick no I'm not sick
any pain I have
I I can forget about it yeah it's
growing it's strengthening it's crazy
um I keep trying to say something and
then remembering and forgetting it just
oh did you see what Rihanna said I
actually really liked what she said I
think the question was like are you
nervous or whatever and she was like
honestly after giving birth like nothing
scares me like I'm a mom I could
literally do anything and I kind of
loved that mindset like obviously I've
never given birth but it's one of my
biggest fears and I imagine once I
hopefully God willing bro Hashem conquer
it like uh you will not find me being
nervous about a single goddamn thing
yeah I was actually just thinking about
that the other day it reminds me of that
scene from Ted where Tammy is uh what's
her name
Mila Kunis and she's like I've given
birth [__] that's so true I have given
birth [__] do you have that sentiment
like nothing scares you anymore
um
not not so like
directly like if I still we're still
going to do a big performance like yeah
I would get scared but like I do feel
like
you know I know pain
so true like you know what no one on
this planet nose pain more than women
who have given birth yeah
yeah
um
I don't know then you start to think of
all different pain yeah but like it's a
big you know physical pain it's a big
thing to do it's like that episode of
Friends what do you think is worse pain
getting like okay hard in the nuts or
giving birth I still say giving birth
yeah like if you're getting like kicked
in the nuts like getting like find new
friends like what are you doing totally
you know if you want to have a baby
there's actually there's two ways out
but
yeah no I definitely could see myself
taking the C-section route like recover
they say recovery is harder so it's like
short-term gain long-term pain and then
I think also I think they say you can
only have three C-sections not that I'm
like you know trying to have eight kids
like you never know yeah then you'd have
to switch so right I would uh but a lot
of people do like elective C-sections
there are definitely there's pros and
cons to everything that's a lot such as
life such is life there actually was an
episode in The Mindy Project about that
and what did they say Mindy she's so me
like I was obsessed she was pregnant
spoiler alert and she's like she booked
this like fancy like best Suite in the
hotel I mean in the hospital uh she
scheduled her C-section and when her
boyfriend the father found out he was
like you're gonna take the easy way out
and I was like okay leave this [__]
alone like [__] off
um and then he actually like ended up
like getting to Mindy and she did it she
was so proud of herself but like I don't
think really like C-section is like such
an easy way out they're still getting
like major surgery and like literally
your your organs are like on a table
yeah I don't think it's such an easy way
out so she wound up doing vaginal and
she was so proud of herself because she
was shamed into it she was literally
shamed into it Danny like the character
who's like her OTP in the show such a
dick like oh speaking of dicks
you and I when we were together like two
nights ago decided to just like
mindlessly watch Laguna Beach when I got
home last night I got way into season
one
I'm obsessed I don't ever remember
watching this show like nothing is even
remotely familiar to me except like the
bones you know Kristen Steven Laura all
right now watching at our 18 Kristin or
team LC Beyond team Christian let me
tell you why Kristen is me she's so
[__] negative like every time she
shows up somewhere she's like can we
leave this sucks I want to go home she's
never once been happy on the show for
one minute she had this restaurant oh
this sucks let's go home like she's so
if I was around her I would want to kill
her but I'm self-aware enough to know
like that's literally me everywhere I
get somebody could we go home let's play
songs
um and you know what she didn't really
do anything to Lauren if anything when
the show started Christian and Stephen
were together like Lauren's the one
being like they keep calling Kristen
[__] actually Lauren is being quite
[__] but the crazy thing and for how
times have changed so much first of all
I kept sending you videos
literally once an episode one of the
characters uses the r word like Steven's
like this salad tastes weird and Chris
it's like yeah because the dressings are
weird I was like I rewind and put on
captions I'm like did I just hear that
they say it so many times and then when
they go to Cabo Kristen's like done with
Stephen and she's like dancing on the
bars like being cute and she wants to
hang out with this guy Sam and literally
I don't know how we were all like
drooling over Stephen she pulled he
pulls her out of the club
screaming in her face grabbing her arm
you're a [__] you're a [__] you're just
[__] [__] [__] and she like is so
unfazed by it Queen but I'm like and
then everyone's like good for you
Stephen I'm like yeah it was honestly so
toxic I couldn't believe what I was
seeing and it's really just a moment in
time what year was that because we were
like Middle School 2007. yeah yeah
around then it is a time capsule of the
culture our word [__] and it's totally
acceptable like no all the girls were
like Stephen good for you Kristen was
acting really [__] like it's insane I
know to like when you watch it with our
the lens of like the world that we live
in now it's really crazy but for the
time like that was par for the course oh
and that's why we were all like walking
around Middle School saying the r word
like everyone was well everyone I mean
it was on the radio like uh the Laguna
Beach didn't invent the r word
if anyone tries to cancel them now for
saying the r word no start with Fergie
it was a part of the culture I mean
Entourage they say it all the time in
the first season it's just so jarring to
hear a forbidden word like not bleeped
out it's not bleeped yeah I'm I wonder
how the cast feels about it being back
on because I know that like Christmas
talked about it they obviously have the
re-watch show and I know that they are
really embarrassed by things that they
did like I when Lauren went on back to
the beach like she apologized to Kristen
for calling her a [__] she was like
that's so [__] up that I said that
like that that was like one of her
biggest regrets right
I'm sure they're all texting each other
like there's worse
guys it was shocking like this Bob but
I'm enjoying it so much I'm obsessed
with Christian like and I'm just
obsessed with the way
they were like they've just skyrocketed
to fame and they were so normal and they
had like such normal bodies and like it
was just like everything oh but then
like they went to this fashion show it
was Rebecca Minkoff I was dying they
went to this fashion show like Trey like
all the ancillary characters like you
could not catch me remembering who the
[__] Morgan was okay and then like that
other girl I think her name was
Christina she went to New York for
spring break instead of Cabo and her
like mom got her an audition I remember
her and she auditions on Broadway and
she sings only hope which is so
quintessential of the times she was so
[__] horrible it was the best scene
of my whole life like I was obsessed but
you could not catch me remembering who
anyone is except for like the main four
like low Elsie Kristen I remembered that
Kristen friend girl who was like so Alex
Kristen's ass yeah
um she had taste like she knew what was
good
um but in this scene what scene was I
talking about
uh okay fashion show and it's Elsie
Steven and Steven's friend who got the
tickets the blonde guy Trey or whatever
Talon no Trey
so they're talking about how like models
are really unattractive when they're so
skinny like just like talking about
bodies like you would just never talk
like that now like I agree like to be so
under you know underweight it's scary
but like it was just it's so indicative
of like the difference in the shift in
the culture it it's really should be
studied
that's so funny it's so good I wonder if
they like wake over [__] like that or
they also all say like they haven't
re-watched it they might not even know
like what's in there yeah but that also
might be why they won't reach it because
like they don't like they don't want to
know no and it's just so crazy our
perception because at the time it was
like Elsie was so cool Kristen was
coming for her neck but like nobody
could touch Elsie and when I've gathered
from watching the first five episodes
it's like Elsie is The Biggest Loser all
she does is like sit around her house
and sit around Laguna Beach waiting for
Stephen to call she like goes out with
like Steven and his friends and like
hangs on and she's like a loser and all
of her friends are like starting to drop
her like those other two girls Christina
and Morgan like don't want to hang out
with her in low anymore because they're
like they're unscrupled and the other
two girls like they're virgins and like
they have like they're just like
different and it's just I don't remember
it being like that I was like nobody is
cooler than else see really on the show
out of all them the last one I'd want to
be is I'll say yeah but I think also the
show and she said this on back to the
beach like the show makes her look even
more pathetic they have like these like
longing like gazes between her and
Stephen where like they probably weren't
even looking at each other but like the
way that they frame it and they put some
music on it yeah that it's constantly
like this narrative under the show like
The One That Got Away is LC but it's not
like really and Lauren said this she
said what I didn't realize I rewatched
the first season when I knew I was
coming on this podcast and I had kovid
was that like Kristen and Steven were in
love like they have it's a love story
between the two of them like an Elsie is
in the way big dope energy yeah and the
music I mean it's the score is just
there's so many songs on there you don't
remember we got more bounce in
California than all your combined so
good Champagne Supernova in the sky like
whatever I'm sure there's like a Laguna
Beach playlist I need to listen to it
it's so good you should so that's my
little recap I and you know the episodes
are actually five minutes long which is
why I love it because they're like 30
minute episodes but with broken down
with commercials it's like 21.
I I'll be done I'll be done later today
amazing so good are you gonna watch like
the next season when Kristen's a senior
and are you gonna watch probably would
you watch The Hills after I don't know
I'm like the hills is all about Lauren
and I'm like kind of hating Lauren yeah
Kristen is as cute as a button like
she's like she's just adorable like
she's the same thing every day like a
black tank top black low-rise jeans and
a black choker and it's just iconic with
her like short like surfer girl hair
yeah Steven takes her surfing and she's
like
this sucks can we go home like it's so
funny so much of re-watching old shows
is like realizing how at the time that
we watch him like we were all really
wrong you know what it always reminds me
of when Melissa gorgo went on Real
Housewives of New Jersey and we were all
like riding so hard for Teresa at the
time that like we all hated Melissa and
it's like Melissa is a sweet nice girl
like why can't we like her too yeah
Teresa treated her so poorly yeah Teresa
she's the worst it's like
we were in too deep and guess who turned
out to be the worst tree
Trey tree who loves her dress
I love my future daughters Trey not to
be confused with Trey
okay are you ready for our next story
yeah
I didn't hear an audible yes
oh I said yes oh okay great thank you
for the enthusiasm
um Helena hutchins's parents and sister
are suing Alec Baldwin and Russ
producers
the Ukrainian parents and sister of
cinematographer Helena Hutchins filed a
lawsuit on Thursday against Alec Baldwin
and the producers of rust in connection
with her death in October 21 2021
attorney Gloria Allred announced the
lawsuit at a press conference on
Thursday morning Alec is also facing a
charge of involuntary manslaughter in
Santa Fe New Mexico and he is due to
appear in court remotely in to answer
for that charge on February 24th
um so everyone has denied culpability in
Hutchinson's death and pointing to
mistakes made by others that allowed a
live round to be introduced to the set
in violation of Industry Safety
standards Helena hutchins's husband
Matthew filed his own wrongful death
lawsuit a year ago on behalf of himself
his wife's estate and the couple's son
the lawsuit is in the process of being
settled and Matthew Hutchins is signed
on as an executive producer of the film
which is due to resume production in the
next weeks he said in a statement I have
no interest in engaging in
recriminations or attribution of blame
all of us believe Helena's death was a
terrible accident at the press
conference Gloria Allred said that
um Helena's family supports Matthew and
is not second guessing his decision to
settle he they said quote the settlement
was for Matthew and his child and we are
now representing others in the family
mom dad and sister and there has been no
settlement for them okay got it so he
settled therefore he has to like you
know appear like outwardly say you know
we're good no and like he's not gonna
like join this suit he's got his own
suit and yeah it's come to an end but
the family and him seem to be okay with
each other's different battles yeah
they're not outwardly being like you
shouldn't settle or anything like that
the only thing that I don't understand
and so like maybe it would make a lot of
sense if I understood it is like the
executive producer credit yeah I guess
that's maybe just a way of getting him
more settlement like as a part of his
deal like we'll pay you the sum
but you know if the movie makes any
money the movie in which your wife
tragically died on like you be a part of
it too you know what I mean
yeah it's weird for sure in the way that
it sounds but I have to I have to assume
it's just a way of getting him more
money
yeah
it's still so crazy to me that this show
will be going on it's the weirdest thing
if Alec Baldwin gets charged will he
still be in the star so like the way I
see it is like with the charges it's so
frustrating because it really was an
accident but at the end of the day
someone died and like we still don't
really know how and like someone is to
blame and I don't know if that means
like because they you know negligence
means they should spend the rest of
their life in prison I don't think it
was Alec but um
it's like something needs to happen like
somebody died a child lost their mom a
young woman lost her life
um and I do think that like these
lawsuits and like these civil like suits
are probably like the best way
to get some sort of Justice
um because while it's a terrible thing
that happened like I don't know
if there's really was any bad intent I
think it was just like somebody [__]
up I don't know that there was bad
intent but like why was alive around on
and if it was the person who's in charge
of ballistics are they also the same
person that loaded a gun and they know
the difference between the live round
and
because that even if it's not malicious
which I don't think it is it's like rose
gross negligence and like
there are consequences yeah
it's it is still the most crazy
unbelievable thing that I think has
happened in the last 10 years it's so
sad and I had also read remember those
Turnt videos of Hilaria and Alec like
pulled over on the side of the road
talking to Paparazzi and hilarious like
filming it and Alex telling her to shut
up all the interviews and all like
everything he said that's all now able
to be used against him yeah which we
always have known which is why when
Erica Jane says like I can't talk about
it it's frustrating but like you do
understand because everything she says
will be used against her and twisted so
if you don't give them anything they
can't twist it yeah
yeah
and it's so crazy I can't believe this
would be still coming out like who would
go see that not even it's not even that
it's coming out because like if it was a
rap if it was somehow done and they just
like put it out right then maybe it's
like okay you know Helena's last work
but like that they're going back to
a set right and finishing it yeah they
really need to just let it go
seriously
are you ready for our next story yes
Misha Barton an old interview with her
is resurfacing where she said that she
was told to sleep with Leonardo DiCaprio
when she was just 19. in the 2005
interview which has resurfaced following
DiCaprio's recent sightings with 19 year
old model Eden Palani the OC star
recalled how her then publicist had
urged her to bed the notorious Playboy
who was 30 at the time Barton who's Now
37 told what is now Harper's Bazaar that
her rep said go and sleep with that man
when they saw DiCaprio at a photo shoot
in Malibu what's more the actors claimed
she had been advised to do so for the
sake of her career Misha told the
magazine she had no interest in dating
an older man before asking isn't he like
30 or something at the time he was just
back on the market following his split
from Giselle page six has reached out to
Reps for Leo and Misha for further
comment so this is like a like just a
crazy anecdote but like
and maybe Leo has something going on but
like this story to me I do not find
Leonardo DiCaprio culpable no like if I
flex really poorly on the publicist the
the rep like yeah
no I agree like this is just an
interesting story given what's going on
and I see how people like can be making
connections but if you actually read it
Leonardo didn't you know
prompt her no proposed sex like I don't
even think they ended up speaking so
it's like I think it's more indicative
of like how disgusting Hollywood can be
and like how that's the culture to like
Pawn off your 19 year old client to [__]
a man 11 years older than her just for
like Fame
and that's mortifying for the publicist
but it doesn't really say much about Leo
no not at all other than that his
girlfriend's become famous which like we
know right
we know so like why don't you track down
the publicist internet yeah let's get a
name
no like I don't need a name but like why
you reach out to Leo for comment like
literally he's like done a lot of weird
[__] but like this actually isn't one of
those I know I completely agree like if
we're gonna do like some expose like
there's more better things to expose
yeah but um
I could see it
yeah for sure and even now like cute
couple no at the time I mean now we're
so
like jaded that 19 and 30 oh that's not
bad that's better than Scott Disick
right I mean it's better than 19 and 48
Leo right now Eden
um and like you know she really went
back when she was 19 she was totally his
type that was like his Blake Lively bar
rafaeli Giselle era like really tall
slender beautiful women and you know
what it would have been cute but good
for Misha obviously has like good
parents and like had like a good head on
her shoulders because I think you know
if you were 19 and like super famous and
you just were kind of Free Falling like
you would just you would just do it yeah
no but she's had her troubles yeah
that's true we need a Misha Memoir yeah
me actually title Misha's memoir
no no no meat no no hold on
it's time you heard it from me love
all about Misha that's actually a good
title Me Myself and Misha I love that
Misha come on Misha's on the Hills I
know that's what I was thinking when you
said that story I'm like what a weird
that was like a weird thing they did
that Hillary it's honestly first of all
she was amazing she was only on for one
season and I thought it was going to be
weird because it's like don't bring this
person into doing this show especially
because she was on the OC which Laguna
Beach was modeled after so it was like
you know it was kind of like Tinsley
Mortimer becoming unreal houses yeah
it's like it was like yes we're too big
the art meets the artist yeah exactly
but one it's actually pretty cool that
it came full circle that you wound up
being on the show that like was inspired
by her original show for I could be
talking about either Tinsley or Misha
but I'm talking about Misha and two oh
my God I loved her she was I didn't
really like her she was such a good
friend she gave such good advice she was
so not like
Obsession and I don't know why she
didn't get a second season probably
because she wasn't all those things and
like she wasn't toxic and she was just a
good person I was under the assumption
she didn't want to come back like that's
how I saw it well she went for the first
one why wouldn't I think she just was
like a little boring for them
um I liked her I loved her yeah
I missed I didn't love that reboot
though
no no no no no I miss her well the
reboot's over too yeah I know I think
that's for the best
yeah was Kristen on the on the reboot
the second so I don't know about the
second season because I only watched the
first but she was filming very Cavalier
and there was like you know
complex I feel like by the time they did
the second season which was literally
like not very long ago
she was available again I feel like
she's on it I think that's part of the
reason why I like the show didn't really
succeed they didn't get like the major
players
yeah
no and it's like everyone is like
married and has kids and it's right it's
different it's different yeah
are you ready for our next story if it's
the next story that is brought to you by
away is it it is a way big suitcases
bags and other travel accessories
designed to make moving through the
world a lot more seamless which is a
good thing because travel makes us
better people by giving us different
perspectives so no matter where you're
going you can always rely on a Waze
range of travel products to solve real
travel problems and get you out there we
are away girlies every suitcase I have
whether it's check size carry-on size is
from away I love so many things about
the way one it comes with a laundry bag
so like your dirty undies don't get like
all smelly up your clean clothes it has
that like you know middle pouch where
you can put all your like little
negliges it's really built to last it's
designed really well it has those four
360 degree spinner Wheels it makes a
smooth roll through an airport even if
your airport has a carpet which is
beyond um
so they make suitcases bags other travel
Essentials and they're made of different
materials like polycarbonate and
aluminum they come in a variety of
colors variety of sizes so whatever
you're packing wherever you're going
their luggage will make you happy will
melt make help make your next trip
seamless they're built to last they're
durable lightweight exteriors they can
withstand even the roughest of baggage
handlers again they have those four 360
degree spinner Wheels you get the
smoothest roll they also come with the
TSA approved combination lock that keeps
all your belongings safe they also offer
free shipping and Returns on any
non-personalized order within the
contingency US Canada and the UK start
your 100-day trial so everything that
they make they give you a 100-day trial
take it out on the road live with it
love with it travel with it if you
decide it's not for you you can return
any non-personalized items for the first
100 days so get that full uh 100-day
trial and Shop the entire away lineup of
travel Essentials including their
best-selling suitcases
um and bags at awaytravel.com toast
that's a way travel.com toast
thank you turdy we got more bounds in
California then all your combined
next up Jennifer Coolidge says that she
studied Mortuary makeup before acting
and she needed she was not the best
escaping Phaedra Parks it's giving
Paulette bonafonte
literally literally literally
the actress who starred as the Nail Tech
and makeup Guru in Legally Blonde
recently spoke to Vogue about her new
Super Bowl commercial for Elf cosmetics
and along with sharing her love for the
retailers affordable makeup she shared
that her career almost took a very
different path quote I sort of thought
that maybe I'd be a makeup artist but I
was not the best in the class and who
wants to be sort of mediocre at
something if you pick that as a career
she attended the Joe Blasco School in LA
to study special effects fashion and
Beauty in a curriculum that included a
mortuary makeup class though there were
no cadavers included in the class while
she didn't end up going to the funeral
home route and chose acting instead the
actress did learn a thing or two during
Beauty School
she said if you have dark under eyes
like black or blue you can actually mix
orange makeup in with your concealer and
will completely cover the blue or yellow
to cover redness it's called color
correction yeah yeah well when Jennifer
says it like it's different it's better
wait so this also begs the question now
a conversation we had a few weeks ago
about jobs you never want to have is
like being a mortician slash like you
know getting bodies ready formaldehyde
makeup clothing is that something you
could ever do where can well no morgue
Tings I don't think I could do well
that's different than a funeral morgue
is like autopsies you like open up
people's bodies no that would be an
autopsy or no that's that and that
happens no but there are the people who
like you know are in charge of
organizing the morgue like being doing
an autopsy is like a special skill set
yeah yeah you said you're saying you
would never want to be like an organizer
at the morgue I would never want to be
an organizer at the morgue a morganizer
would you no
would you want to do autopsies no I
think doing an autopsy is probably worse
than being like a you know funeral
makeup and clothing yeah I could sooner
do funeral makeup yeah I wouldn't want
to I mean it's like that episode of the
simple life which had to have been fake
when they like had the job spray tanning
dead people oh my God that had to I'd
rather do funeral makeup than be a
morganizer
yeah me too
I mean I'm just don't I I don't know how
I would be around dead bodies I mean
I've I've been around one in my life and
it was like a loved one so
it's just I can't even I can't like okay
I can't even continue the conversation
and we don't even know like really what
goes down because in in Judaism you bury
the person the day after they die so
there's no you know formaldehyde you
don't do like pump up their body but in
other cultures you know you wait weeks
and by the time the body like it needs
all that stuff so I don't know what that
stuff is because we don't do that would
you rather be a morganizer or do beach
chairs on the beach
I don't know it's really cold in the
morgue
and I think I would like the temperature
you could wear your sweatshirt so okay
but what's the morganizer like what's
what's my responsibilities okay pull
like the drawers open yeah like when a a
person comes in I I mean I don't know
what they're like I'm gonna just do
hypothetical hypothetical person comes
in on the track and she's right
the stretcher and you have to put them
in the drawer tag it are they already in
the bag I
yeah they're already in the bag properly
but maybe you need to put a tag on their
toe or something yeah
I mean I'd have to say the beach you'd
get tan
but honestly it's a it's a tough maybe
you'll get like maybe you could get you
get like you know some free fries at the
beach club that's true start thinking of
the positives yeah you would get so
skinny oh my God I would be so fit like
athletic like strong hands tan I
actually probably end up looking like a
little leathery like a purse skinny as a
needle
skinny as a needle
um
so
yeah Jennifer Coolidge chose to be an
actress instead I think that's the best
because she seems to be pretty good at
it
yeah she's one of a kind you know the
industry wouldn't be the same one of a
kind I couldn't have said there are a
lot of actresses we discuss all the time
actors actresses who like could be
replaced with another could be
interchangeable you don't even know who
they are yes but you don't get Jennifer
Coolidge confused with anybody else
she's a once in a lifetime Talent yeah
in it like but it's not that she's more
talented she's the most Talent Time
personality yeah because like
she's Jennifer yeah she's in her own
lane
and you gotta run your own race turdy
yeah and I don't think like she's out
here competing with other actresses like
I think people are actually creating
roles for her yeah
yeah are you ready for our fifth and
final story which is a little podcasting
news oh always ready to you know read
the industry to filth yeah unexpected
podcasting news and um I don't know how
much filth you're gonna be able to
read okay
Winnie the Pooh has gotten a podcast
deal at baboon animation Go kid go after
revealing a film prequel in series to
A.A milne's beloved book Winnie the Pooh
baboon animation has set a five property
podcast deal with Go kid go starting
with stories from the Pooh Corner
working title the podcast I think that's
a title that needs to change sounds like
a corner full of [__]
the podcast like the feature we'll
explore the characters young lives
before the tales in the book took place
and Will acquaint preschool-aged
children with all the classic Pals for
miln's Hundred Acre Wood and introduce
new characters these younger characters
will have big fresh appeal for a brand
new kid audience I don't know do you
think really complex for like a kid do
you think Winnie the Pooh can make it in
this day and age with these kids I don't
I was going up against Coco melon he's
going up against baby shark no and I do
think there is like a place for
podcasting but for kids like I like I
really think Miss Rach would have a
really popular podcast like basically
audio versions of her of her videos
however
um I think it's hard to keep kids
attention when it's just audio that's
why like Miss Rachel's singing and like
all that stuff I would say you're in the
car like I don't expect them to like put
on no I know but like iPad
like I'm saying you're competing with
like Coco melon yeah people have iPads
in the car yeah so I think like a back
story about like it's too complex for a
podcast for kids I don't know I think it
could be done I'd rather have my kid
listen to a podcast in the car than
watch a screen just because yeah of
course motion sickness yeah that's why I
think like Miss rage not uploading her
videos as podcasts is a huge loss Miss
reach if you hear this free idea yeah or
someone could like rip the audio yeah or
just like play their phone YouTube for
sure but like get on another platform Mr
H yeah because also sometimes the kids
are sitting backwards so it's like
you're traveling backwards and you're
watching something on the screen
couldn't be me oh and you might be
having a snack vomit it's so true maybe
drinking some milk yeah but kids are
[__] you know they're crazy they're
crazy they're they do [__] we could
never do like they love to be thrown
around and tossed and they don't even
get dizzy no it's wild out there but um
I like the idea of kids podcasting I
mean of course it then starts to compete
with us because then the parents in the
car you know all of a sudden they could
be like we're in the car we have to
listen to Mommy show but now the sudden
kid goes what about Winnie the Pooh Mom
right turn on Miss reach
turn on Coco melon Coco melon is getting
a podcast I think are they we report on
kids podcasts you know a couple times a
year I've heard so much about Coco melon
like I've for years everyone's like my
kids it's like crack and I only saw it
for the first time like a couple weeks
ago when Michaela was watching and I was
like this is what everyone's obsessed
with like I thought it was like very low
budget I thought their songs stunk it up
they were like half not even on melody
in their Rhymes Like weren't even that
inspired I was like I could do better I
really I was shocked that this was like
the thing everyone was obsessed with no
it's addictive and then you realize
they're getting addicted to mediocrity
oh
you know so true we need our kids to
Aspire to do better yeah
so I'm anti-coco melon I I you have my
full support
thank you you know Mickey Mickey could
have a podcast hiya kids totally let's
get our mousektools we're going for a
car ride on a road trip dog hot dog hot
digging dog
hot dog hot dog hot diggity dog so good
but
you guys went down Club put on the toast
for your kids yeah sure we curse
sometimes
such as life
thanks yummy soda but like if you guys
were like if we got a lot of actually
like if we got a lot of comments that
were like I literally would love to
listen to you guys with my kids in the
car like the me the songs the the rhythm
of the girlies Etc the you know the
vocabulary
um but like I let you guys curse way too
much like I really can't I personally
would make a conscious effort to curse
us I'm not saying that I could do it I
would try I I first of all I wouldn't
because it's literally impossible for me
to stop cursing it is that's like you
asking me to stop saying the word like
it's just we've gotten so much better
turdy though with like yeah like from
our first early days oh when we go back
and watch old episodes like the like the
like it's horrible yeah so I think we
could improve I think we could improve
too yeah I definitely think we're better
with the life because practicing talking
every day like you become so conscious
of it pot free idea for the apps you
like Spotify or apple should have a
feature where you could bleep curse
words when you're listening to it just
like on captions on Instagram stories
they would like you know scan through
your episode
that's a great idea someone needs to
invent that technology and sell it and
then and then if it like Spotify had it
then everybody would listen on Spotify
yeah oh my God that's like literally why
do we have to change why don't you guys
work on that we have so many good ideas
that we like to throw out here but that
might be your best one yet it's like
it's kind of like a million dollar idea
it's kind of a billion dollar idea if
only you think you could sell the
Spotify no I think it would sell to
Spotify for like
50 mil no I think not only Spotify like
every platform there's so many major
billion dollar media companies that need
that yeah Pandora
because you could use it for music too
yeah
get to work someone get to work someone
someone who's in that field of
programming of like to wear coding that
nine-year-old kid who graduated I have a
lot of things for him to work on me too
he should also like work on kids
television yeah what should inspiring
kids watch right that's not Coco melon
that will make them more like you more
educational content I wonder what he if
he ever chooses to relax what he watches
how he winds down such a good question I
mean they gotta get him on the toast we
do
um so those were the Fast Five they were
actually pretty good and it was a nice
episode you know
kind of easing us back into the remote
setup it's the last one of the week last
one before Super Bowl so I hope everyone
has a great time at the Super Bowl make
sure to eat a ton root hard you know
enjoy the Rihanna concert it's very
exciting it is exciting we'll see you on
Monday and
we'll know we'll know more then we'll
know more than and we will have a full
recap but maybe up until halftime
because I might have to go to sleep it
might be my bedtime thank you guys so
much for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show are one thousand
and first episode we go live every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching this on YouTube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so on Spotify iTunes Stitcher
public radio I really guess books all
the places
talented we are wicked I hope you guys
have an amazing weekend we love you and
we'll see you on Monday love you bye